there was this strange war on white
people in our day which a lot of people
even just hearing that phrase go you
know worry but it's absolutely the case
racism in our day is rightly deemed to
be totally impermissible
in the public square with one exception
which is white people about whom you can
say absolutely anything now
and people do and i give a remorseless
number of examples in the book i mean if
if any group of people if if you took
what is now said about white people in
america britain and elsewhere and said
it about any other group
you would be regarded rightly as a
racist uh in several a lot of countries
you'd be locked up for hate speech uh
but this is now not just normal rhetoric
but instilled and installed
in every area of government
in countries including britain and the
united states
it's instilled through the media
through academics
through the military through absolutely
every level of our societies
uh
white people are seen as being a problem
and
a problem
for whom a remedy must be found
now of course some of the maniacs who
have been pushing this like robin
d'angelo who herself is white and of
course the author of white fragility
which sold about half a million copies
after the death of george floyd
um
says there is no good form of being
white
no good form of being white
and
there's a rider
you also can't escape it
you can't escape it
so you can't like shift to another
racial group you can't identify as not
being white if you're white she doesn't
know what it is
and i don't think anyone really does
it's a very weird category to even talk
about people in these contexts
you know
but
if you said that about any other group
of people if you said there is no good
form of blackness
none
and
don't ever try to stop being black
because you can't you can't get out of
it
we'd go wow
that's a racist
that's a big racist right there
well it's racist when they do it about
white people as well
uh
the talk of white privilege has become a
racist trope quite clearly
uh the talk of white tears
white female tears try that any other
way black tears black female tears
oh she's just crying black tears oh
you'd say that's a that's a racist
uh so it is when they say white tears or
that white rage when the ones that
they've um in this attempt to
pathologize being white
they've come up with most recently
particularly the week of january the
sixth white rage uh no less a figure
than general milly the chairman of joint
chiefs of staff from the u.s testifying
for congress
addressed the issue of so-called white
rage said i want to learn about white
rage i want to find out what it is
let's try the other way around one more
time
black rage
let's look into it
oh you'd say that doesn't sound like a
very nice thing to do why don't we just
talk about rage in general
white rage black rage
only one of those is a permissible thing
to talk about only one of those you'd
catch the chairman of the joints of
staff using before congress
where does this asymmetry come from then
is it because white people are seen to
it's always punching up toward white
people is it this
current trend that we have toward
anti-westernism
colonialist imperialists reparations
need to come from the past and that
white people are
and that skin color is a representation
of that as an ideology or as a
like the day um tip of the spear of
of that history i think it's an attempt
to um
rectify a historic wrong had a wildly
misguided attempt at it
so
i mean i think we talked about this when
we talked about the matters of crowds we
talked about the fact that there's
there's such a thing as an over
correction in social issues you know
nobody denies that women historically
were not able to make the same life
choices as men were able to make they
didn't have as much freedom in in
general
um they didn't and so if you want to
make up for that historic wrong
the obvious thing to do is just make
everyone equal
a certain type of person says no we we
can make up it faster by punishing men
for a time
uh nobody can deny that gay people
historically were not treated equally as
straight people
uh there's a type of person who says
let's attack the heterosexuals for a bit
um instead of saying why don't we just
have equality
um in the same way nobody with any sense
would be able to deny that historically
racism has existed in countries
of the west as it has in all countries
it's a very very ugly human instinct one
of the worst
uh and it exists in it it exists in
particular american society exists still
there are still pockets of racism in
america not not
legitimate or in any way mainstream but
but there are some people who will hold
racist views and um but they're all on
the margins
uh nevertheless you can't deny that
historically america has been a white
dominated country in which black people
were oppressed for a very long time and
until not that long ago
what do you want to do to make up for
that again you have the same options as
you have women other minority issues you
can decide to go for equality or you can
decide to overdo it for a bit
uh over correct and the over correction
in race is let's beat up on the white
people for a bit what's happening people
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the full unedited episode and don't
forget to subscribe
peace
you